Transcriber: Yomna Mehena
المدقّق: Eman Sabry
"تصفيق"
"نيل ارمسترونج"
لقد حدثونا كثيراً عن هذه الصورة
أن هذا أول انسان يصل الي سطح القمر
ولقد حدثونا أيضاٌ عن اقتباسه الشهير
خطوة صغيرة لإنسان ولكنها خطوة
عظيمة للبشرية.
ولكن لم يخبرونا
من هو أول من نظر الي القمر؟
ما كان تخيلهم عن القمر؟
و كيف عرفوا مكان القمر؟
لكي نصل إليه في يوم من الأيام
ونلتقط هذه الصورة.
هذه الصورة شهيرة جداٌ، صورة
المجموعة الشمسية.
جميع كتب العلوم للمرحلة الابتدائية تحتوي
علي هذه الصور.
هذه الكتب تشرح كم كوكب يدور حول الشمس
ومن الممكن أن يُحدد مقدار بُعد
كُل كوكب عن الشمس.
ولكن لم يخبرنا أحد
من هو أول من أدرك وفكر
ما علاقة الشمس بالكواكب؟
وما علاقة هي الأرض بالشمس؟
أكان يُعتَقد أنها وُجِدت هكذا
أم أن هناك نموذج آخر
وعبرنا عدة مراحل قبل الوصول لهذا النموذج؟!
لم يخبرنا أحد.
الصورة القادمة لم يخبرنا أحد عنها
بالكثير من التفاصيل.
لقد أخبرونا بتفاصيل فوق الطبيعي
لكنها غير محددة.
أخبرونا ما هي الخلية ؟
ومما تتكون؟
حتي وصل الحد أن يخبرونا
مكونات جدار الخلية.
لكن لم يخبرنا أحد
من هو أول من رأي الخلية؟
ولماذا أطلق عليها اسم الخلية؟
دائماً ما يخبرونا بالمعلومات لكن
لا يخبرونا بمصدرها
شئ آخر يحدث كل يوم ولم يخبرنا أحد مصدرها.
تمرض فتذهب الي الطبيب ليفحصك.
ليسألك أسئلة غريبة وأنت تجيب إجابات أغرب.
و من المُفترض أن يفهم الطبيب مما تُعاني.
وعندما يُعطيك دواء من المفترض أن يُشفيك.
ولكن من أخبر الأطباء
ما هو الفحص؟
ومن أخبرهم أنهم إذا وضعوا السماعة في
مكان معين سيسمعون صوت محدد
لو هذا الإنسان لدية قلب سليم.
ولو تغير الصوت الي صوت آخر
فإن هذا الشخص مريض.
ليس أي مرض بل مرض بعينه
وعندما تعطيه الدواء اللازم سيُشفي.
أسئلة أسئلة أسئلة
وللأسف لم تصلني إلي أي إجابة.
بل قادتني إلي سؤال آخر.
هل يجب أن نعرف مصادر العلوم التي نتعلمها؟
لدينا الكثير من المعلومات.
لدينا الكثير من الحقائق هي أساساً مثبتة
هل يجب علينا أن نعرف مصدرها ؟
أم علينا أن نكتفي بمعرفة الحقائق نفسها
هذا هو السؤال المطروح.
وأتمني أن أستطيع الإجابة
عليه في النهاية.
سأقُص عليكم بعض القصص.
أول قصة هي قصة المجموعة الشمسية.
ما هو تاريخ المجموعة الشمسية؟
وكيف بدأت؟
لنحكي هذه القصة يجب أن نعود بالزمن.
في الحقيقة يجب أن نعود كثيراً.
نحن الآن في القرن السادس عشر
وفي القرن السادس عشر كان هناك أحد العلماء
ينظر لأعلي إلي الشمس ويتأمل فيها.
ويفكر ما هي علاقة الشمس التي يراها
بالأرض التي يسكنها؟
هذا العالم هو "تيكو براهي".
دنماركي من أشهر علماء الفلك في ذلك الوقت.
في الوقت الذي طرح فيها تيكو براهي
هذه الأسئلة.
كان البشر بالفعل مؤمنين بأن نموذج
بطليموس هو الصحيح.
و الذى كان ينص
أن الارض تقع في مركز
المجموعة الشمسية
ويدور حولها الشمس وباقي الكواكب.
ولكن كان هناك عالم آخر لدية وجهة نظر أخري.
"نيكولاس كوبرنيكوس"
كان يقول "لا" هذه ليست الحقيقة
لكن الحقيقة هي أن الشمس في مركز
المجموعة الشمسية
ويدور حولها الارض وباقي الكواكب
ويدوروا في مدارات دائرية.
ولكن تيكو براهي العالم الدنماركي
كان يرى أن لا هذا ولا ذاك صحيحين مائة بالمائة.
وإنما يحتوي كل منها علي جزء صحيح
فأنتج نموذج هجين بين النظريتين
هذا النموذج استطاع أن يفسر الكثير من
حركات الكواكب حول الشمس وهكذا.
لكن فشل نموذج تيكو براهي في تفسير شئ واحد.
التي لم يستطع تفسيرها.
هذا
"كوكب المريخ"
لم يُفسر حركة المريخ بنموذج تيكو براهي.
لقد فشلت قواعد تيكو براهي بتفسير حركة المريخ.
المريخ كان الإختلاف.
المريخ كان المثال الشاذ الذي لم يستطع تفسيرها.
و ظل بعد الوقت يفكر في المريخ
فقرر أن يمنح هذه المشكلة لأحد مساعديه
الذي كان طموحاَ ويريد أن يحقق شيئا.
"جوهانز كيبلر"
كيبلر نظر للمريخ علي أنها مشكلة
ولابد أن يجد لها حلاً.
لم يفكر بأن المريخ شئ مختلف
فيجب أن يتركه ويضعه جنباً.
أو بأنه صدفة.
لو وُجِدت نظرية لتفسير حركة الأجسام
في الكون.
فلابد أن تُفسِر كل الأجسام دون استثناء.
فلماذا المريخ مختلف؟
جمع كيبلر مشاهدته ومشاهدات علماء آخرين
حتي مشاهدات تيكو براهي بعد موته.
وجد أن !
المدارات ليست دائرية
وهذا هو السبب في حركة المريخ الغريبة.
وإنما شكل هذه المدارات بيضاوية.
هذه القصة توضح أن تأمل ورؤية
تيكو براهي للمريخ.
تختلف عن رؤية كيبلر له.
لقد آمن كيبلر بأن المريخ
شئ لابد من تفسيره
هذه قصة قديمة جداً ولكن
كيف نستفاد منها الآن؟
سنترك القرن السادس عشر ونسافر إلي الأمام
إلي الأمام كثيراً.
عام 2010
في عام 2010
في تجارب الأدوية يجلب العلماء مجموعة
من المرضي ثُم يُعطى لهم الدواء
الجديد لاختباره
لمعرفة مدي استجابتهم للدواء.
في مجال تجربة أدوية السرطان
يعلم الكثيرون أنه بين كل مائة دواء جديد
تسعة وتسعون دواء احتمال كبير أن يفشلوا
و واحد فقط من المحتمل أن ينجح.
لقد بدأ العلماء لتجربة دواء لعلاج
سرطان المثانة البولية
علي مجموعة من المرضي.
كانت النتائج مذهلة جداً.
فشل ذريع!
المريض رقم 1 لا يستجيب.
رقم 10 لا يستجيب.
رقم 40 لا يستجيب.
42،43،44
إلي أن جاءت المريضة رقم 45
مريضة عمرها 73 عاماً.
ينتشر عندها سرطان المثانة البولية
بنسبة كبيرة جداً.
صور الأشعة بها الكثير من الخلايا
السرطانية.
حسناً، لنعطيها الدواء علي سبيل التجربة
في المتابعة وأثناء الفحص
لم يستطع الأطباء تحديد
أين كان أصل الورم؟!
نجاح ساحق.
ولكن هذا النجاح لا شئ.
هذه مريضة واحدة
ووفقاً لأي إنسان يفكر بتفكير علمي صحيح
فإن ملف هذه المريضة لن ينظر إليه أحد
لأنها حالة واحدة
وهناك الكثير من الحالات الفاشلة
وهذا ما يحدث دوماً.
إلي أن جاء شخص وقرر أن يأخذ هذه الحالة
في الاعتبار.
وأن هذه الحالة وهذا الاختلاف
يحمل إجابة لسؤال.
وقرر أن يتبع هذه الحالة.
جلب العلماء الحالة رقم 45.
وكان عندهم في ذلك الوقت تصور بأنه
ما بين 10 إلى 150 جين تغيروا أو حدث لهم
تحور جيني
مربوطين بسرطان المثانة البولية.
ففحص الطبيب تحاليل هذه المريضة ليعرف عدد
الجينات المتغيرة.
فوجد عندها 140 جين حدث لهم تغير.
ولكن جين واحد جذب انتباهه.
وكان العلماء قد تنبؤا مسبقاً بأن هذا الجين له
علاقة بالدواء المُجرب.
ولكن لم يستطع الأطباء أن يثبتوا كيف.
أنا أريد أن أثبتها فماذا أفعل؟
رجع إلي الأربع والأربعين حالة
وأجري لهم التحليل الجيني.
و وجد أن هذا الجين لديهم سليم!
فاستطاع أن يدرك حقيقة لم يعرفها العلماء
إلي الآن وهي:
إن كان الجين سليم، فالدواء ليس له تأثير.
ولو كان فاسداً،فإن الدواء له تأثير.
هذا الدواء كان سيُلقي،
ويُحرم الكثيرون من الاستفادة منه.
ولكن تم انقاذه من الدخول في وادي الموت
مثل الكثير من أدوية السرطان
وحرمان مرضي لديهم هذا الجين المتغير
من فرصة العلاج.
هاتان القصتان يعلمونا أن هناك من
يحترم الاختلاف وتحترم الحالات الشاذة.
وأن من تتبع تلك الحالات الشاذة
فإنك تجد إجابات للكثير من الأسئلة
التي أهملها آخرون لم يجدوا إجابات لها
سأحكي لكم قصة أخري.
هذه القصة محببة لقلبي لأنها متعلقة
بمجال دراستي.
تذهب إلي الطبيب فيفحصك ولكن لا نفهم
كيف عرف الأطباء فن الفحص؟
ما هو مصدر معرفتهم بالمرض
وكيفة حدثه؟ لكي يعالجوه فى النهاية.
الفكرة أنك تسمع الكثيرين يقولون
الفيزياء الحديثة والكيمياء الحديثة
من الممكن أن هذه العلوم ليست حديثة
ولكن العلماء يريدون أن يفرقوا بينها
وبين الفيزياء الكلاسيكية
والكيمياء الكلاسيكية.
ولكن إن ذكر أحد أمامك الطب الحديث
بصراحة إنه شئ جديد!
قبل1930 لم يكن الطب بنفس المفاهيم الحالية.
دكتور"سيدارت موخرجي"
دكتور هندي في مجال دراسة الأورام.
قبل 1930 كان الطب عبارة عن 3 أساسيات
الأساس الأول:الوهم.
بمعني أن المريض يتلقي علاجاً
ولكنه ليس دواء.
وأنه لا يعمل ولا يعالج المرض
ولكن يأخذها المريض
علي أمل أن الإيحاء النفسي
أنه يأخذ دواء يجعله بتحسن.
الأساس الثاني:المسكنات.
المريض في مرحلة متقدمة من المرض
مريض جداً فيأخذ المسكنات
حتي لا يتألم في المرحلة الباقية من حياته.
الأساس الثالث:السباكة.
المريض يعاني من الإمساك
فتعطيه دواء لعلاجه.
وكان الأطباء يستخدمون هذه الأساسيات
مع معظم المرضي، ليس لكفاءة هذه الاساسيات
علي الإطلاق!
ولكننا لا نمتلك حلولاً أخري.
لو تمتلك شكوشاً وهو الاداة الوحيدة
التي تمتلكها
فإن كل الأشياء ستبدو كالمسامير.
إلي أن جاء دكتور وليام أوسلر أو سير وليام
أوسلر ومجموعة من زملائه.
ليوضحوا أن روح قسم أبو قراط
-ليس مكتوب نصاً-
ولكن تدور روح قسم سقراط
"الأهم هو عدم ايذاء المريض".
ولكننا لا نعطي المريض شئ ينفعه
لأننا في الحقيقة لا نعرف ماذا يفيده.
لأننا غير قادرين علي فهم المرض.
فقرر دكتور وليام أوسلر أنه يحول
"اولاً يجب عدم ايذاء المريض" إلي
"أولاً يجب أن لا نفعل شئ."
دعونا نجلس ونراقب بدون أي عمل.
وهذا ما فعله في الواقع.
كان يحجز المرضي في المستشفي
حتي لا يفعل شئ
فقط ليراقبهم ويراقب التطور الطبيعي للمرض.
مريض فشل عضلة القلب الغير قادر علي
صعود السلم
ثم يبدأ في التنفس بسرعة
والتعرق
ثُم يصبح غير قادر علي صعود طابق ومن ثَمَّ
زيادة ضربات القلب.
ثُم يصبح غير قادر علي المشي لأخر الممر.
بعد أن فهمنا مرض فشل عضلة القلب،
أجبنا علي الكثير من الأسئلة لها علاقة بهذا المرض.
ومن ثَمَّ تدخل الأطباء لعلاج هذا المرض.
وقِسْ علي هذا علاج جميع الأمراض الأخري.
قدرتنا علي فهم المريض ومم يشتكي
جاءت من الملاحظة.
فقط!
الفكرة أني أعلم أنه لدينا الكثير من
المعلومات.
مَن مِن الحضور له علاقة بالمجال الطبي
والدراسة الطبية بأي شكل؟
ارفعوا أيديكم.
الكثير ممن له علاقة بالطب يستطيع مثلاً
أن يشرح مما تتكون الخلية.
ومم يتكون وجدار الخلية؟
وتصل إلي أن يخبرك ما هو سمك الخلية؟
ولكن!
إن سألنا أحدهم
كيف اكتشفوا الخلية؟
من أول من أطلق عليها اسم
"الخلية"؟
الكثير منا لن يعرف.
قِسْ علي هذا كل الدراسات في اي مجال مختلف.
لا يعرف أحد مصدرالمعلومات
أو كيف فكر هؤلاء الناس
ليكتشفوا هذه المعلومات؟
نعم! لقد فهمت.
هل تقصدين أن ما نتلقاه من معلومات
ليس كافٍ؟
فنحن لا نستطيع متابعة المذاكرة
والمعلومات التي نتلقاها.
وتريدين زيادة ليس فقط الحقائق
بل مصدرها أيضاً.
الفكرة ليست في كم المعلومات ولكن جودتها.
هل هذه المعلومات تؤهلنا للإجابة علي
الاسئلة التي يطرحها العلم كل يوم؟
هذا سؤال لانعرف إجابته.
يري الكثيرون أن الفلسفة كلام غير هام.
ولكن الكثير من التربويين حول العالم
الكثير ممن درسوا التربية يروا أنه يجب
علي الأطفال في المدارس
كما يتم تعليمهم العلوم والحقائق العلمية.
يدرسوا الفلسفة.
ليس فقط للإجابة علي أسئلة العلم
"لا"
ولكن ليستطيعوا مواجهة تحديات الحياة.
من الناس المؤمنة بأهمية دراسة العلم و
أهمية دراسة تاريخ العلم
"كارل بوبر"
الذى نقل المثل من لورد اكتون في كتابه
"منطق الاكتشافات العلمية"
ما أردت أن أقوله أننا عرضنا قصتين
و عرضنا بعض التسؤلات
ثم وصلنا لتساؤل أكبر
هل نحن في حاجه لدراسة تاريخ العلم؟
هل نحن في حاجه لمعرفة مصدر
هذه المعلومات العلمية؟
ثم عرضت قصتين:
الأولي توضح أهمية الحالات الشاذة.
والثانية توضح أهمية الملاحظة.
قبل نيوتن رأي الكثيرون التفاح وهو يقع
ولكن لم يفكروا فى قوانين للجاذبية.
لنفكر قليلاً، ما هو المشترك بين كل من
الحسن بن الهيثم،
و ابن سينا،و ويليام أوسلر
-الذي تكلمنا عنه- وكيبلر؟
أن هؤلاء جميعاً اهتموا أولاً بالحالات
الشاذة وليس كما يعلمونا
شئ غريب، اتركه أو احفظه
كما هو، احتمال يكون صدفة.
ولكن هؤلاء الناس امنوا بعدم وجود
صُدف في العلم.
ثانياً: أهمية الملاحظة
وأن تتعلم فن الملاحظة
لأن الملاحظة العلمية الدقيقة
ليست شئ عبثي.
لو مر طبيب علي المرضي كل يوم في العنبر،
فإنه يري الكثير من الأشياء الغريبة ولا
يلاحظها، يري ولكنه لا يلاحظ.
الفكرة أنه لم يستطع أحد التنبؤ بأن
ويليام أوسلر سيكون مؤسس الممارسة
الطبية الحديثة كلها،
كما لا يمكننا الجزم اى من
الحضور يمكنه ان يجيب
عن الأسئلة والألغازالتي يطرحها العلم
في الوقت الحالي كل يوم.
قبل الختام لا يوجد شئ يمكن أن يُلخِص
الموضوع في دقائق
لذا أحب أن أشاركم بعض الكتب التي
استعنت بها.
"قوانين العلم"
"العلم الأصغر" للويس توماس
"بوبر" من أشهر من تحدث في فلسفة العلم.
وكتابه"منطق الاكتشافات العلمية"
كنت سعيدة أني معكم
شكراً
"تصفيق"